Hi.
Uh,
we're ready.
All right.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I don't know,
I've just been getting a bunch of guests lately.
It's time for another special one.
And I got another legend,
the legend here.
I got the one and only Stephen Perkins from Jane's Addiction.
Hi Bill Porno for Pyros infectious grooves and your latest project,
the think experience,
which we will be getting into.
Uh,
first off,
thank you so much for doing this.
I've been a,
a,
a huge fan of,
you've already been talking and what happens when you break before you do a
podcast?
It's like,
dude,
just save that,
try and save that.
Say Nothing.
Just let it flow.
Let the levy break.
Yes.
When the mic is on.
So,
um,
we were talking about,
uh,
basically the influence of the Internet and how good these,
these kids are at playing now,
but how it's like,
almost like they all grew up in the same town.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Because everyone can just kind of go on youtube and if there's some sick kid in
Minnesota,
you didn't have to live there to see him.
You just put it on and you watch it and then his influence goes into where you
are and then it's so widespread so quickly and there was such a fine romantic
feeling to find a drummer or a record and fall in love with it and learn how to
plate it.
Uh,
no one else knew what you were working on your home alone.
It could have been a cold train,
it could abandoned van Halen,
it could have been both at the same time,
you know,
and try to kind of fuse this hybrid of yourself alone and the romance of a drum
stick and a and an and the rhythm.
How did you,
how did you come about?
Well,
your style like,
like blew my mind when I first,
I first heard you,
I missed the first few Jane's albums because I was,
I was neck deep in,
in and hair metal and all that.
And,
um,
when ritual came out,
it's just like,
that was the first time I really heard somebody with a,
uh,
that kind of music.
Just the sound of that and just all the snare,
just placement and all that.
It just,
it just wasn't that approach of like,
all right to enforce the snare and then I'm going to do some syncopated shit and
absolutely,
you know,
the base does this and I'm going to follow it with my foot.
And you just had you,
it was completely,
it was like almost upside down.
Like how,
how did you arrive at that?
Well,
I was,
I think the great drummers have great musicians around them and that brings the,
the competition in the jam room brings better performances out of each other.
So I was ultra aware of technique and chops,
but I knew that really wasn't my forte.
I didn't want to be a fast lightening drummer and they really find a place for
that.
And the music I loved,
my early love was jazz buddy rich gene Krupa,
Elvin Jones.
But no one in Los Angeles played trumpet,
Saxophone,
even piano,
right?
No one even played bass.
Everyone played guitar.
So then what are you going to do?
You're going to bite into rock and roll.
But that swung the award from Sabbath bottom.
And then I started to check out what the of Motown men and how that influenced
Ringo and Charlie and Ginger Baker and they were playing these Motown beats but
surrounded by great songwriters,
right?
And so this,
this fusion,
this hybrid of jazz swinging and the flash of rock and roll.
And then I kind of hit a ceiling.
I was bored.
I didn't know what other record to by genesis rush,
everybody,
everything.
And I said,
you know,
I,
I've found through the Beatles probably Indian tabla rhythms and that opened the
door to African rhythms,
which was fella cootie in Bobbitt tune de Ella tune g chase these guys deep.
I have no idea what that these records were just as important as the,
the Abbey road record.
I tried to make that impression on myself.
Let those records become part of how important the rhythm can be,
not just these great songs that you grew up with,
listen to new rhythms.
And so those rhythms started to infuse my creative side.
And then I joined the marching band in high school.
So they have one shot chops and everyone was competitive.
One in first chair and everyone was showing what they had the flash.
So that could be bad for your playing creatively,
but it's good for your endurance and your confidence.
And how did,
how did you,
when were you
mature enough when you went in there to see that this isn't what it's about,
where it's like I would compare that in,
uh,
I'd done a little bit of acting work and in a few,
very rarely,
but a few times I've gotten into a scene with somebody and it's the silly as
this sounds,
they get in like I'm going to out act you.
Yeah,
exactly.
Rather than,
hey,
we're doing this together,
let's,
you know,
let's work together.
They get in,
they're like,
I'm going to out create you.
It's a,
there's a tennis match.
It's going on,
but you can't always ace the guy cause there's no match.
You want to rally.
Right.
So you do want to once in a while it's just,
you know,
slam it in pink wine but you can't slam it every time.
Let's play,
let's rally,
let's laugh,
let's communicate.
And I think growing up in the Varo at 15 on,
it was my love affair with guitar and drums.
I didn't know much about base and that rhythm section yet cause no one played
bass.
I always want it to match the,
I always heard that if you played bass you could get into like 20 bands
immediately.
We ended up using the drums or guitar and sang if find one,
you know?
Right.
So,
but I think when the band Jane's actually kind of to become aware of our,
what was important was the lyrics and the phrasing and he's not going to sing
like this hair metal thing where you sing it four times and then you sing the
next thing four times.
It's not going to rhyme.
It doesn't rhyme.
He says something once and then we react and then he says something three times
and then he says,
motherfucker.
And then you punch it behind them and then,
you know,
and then so it's a poem with song and then,
so I think we started to become ultra aware of it's an emotional performance.
It's real estate.
Where are you going to place yourself and who are we going to get out of the way
of Doodoodoo kick up,
you know,
where are you going to,
where are you going to put your plant?
And it almost like a monopoly game.
You go over and over,
then you buy boardwalk and then you put a house on it.
Then you put a hotel on it.
You make your event more worthy when you guys know when you guys were going in
that direction because he means so much of it is,
you know,
you want to make it.
I mean,
you don't want to be homeless.
And what you guys were doing was so different despite when I listened to it,
you know,
uh,
a lot of your influences were the stuff that those guys that I was listening to
them the metal years were listening to.
When you start to make that departure of like,
this does not sound like what,
what,
you know,
that big thing,
what they're looking for.
Like what are you looking for a man?
What's the look?
This what was going on?
85 the strip was coming to an end,
motley rat poison.
It was already ending.
Then they all been signed and it was repetitive,
redundant to rivet and of each other.
What Jane's addiction would go downtown and there was x and the minute men,
the Chili peppers and fishbone,
and they weren't successful as far as getting signed to a major.
They kind of hit a ceiling.
The punk rock ceiling flag was there for,
you know,
fear.
It was circle jerks.
It was fucking fantastic,
but they weren't going to get any bigger.
I remember x got a song in the Charlie Sheen movie,
the baseball movie,
and I was like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The ex got a song in a movie.
That's what I get.
He said,
because punk rock hit a ceiling.
So there was that moment where metal was done,
punk rock post-punk.
So when you're world metal was done in [inaudible] 85 yeah,
there's already done.
It was gone in my world that then exactly three exact,
it was still poor,
but as it,
as a player,
and to create it as a,
it's,
it was trying to turn the key a little and change,
I didn't want to be Tommy Lee anymore.
You know,
there was a moment you watch like,
because like say,
you know,
you was still a kid.
So MTV was so huge to our generation and,
and you know,
this scene is over.
Yeah.
And,
and right as you're saying,
it's over.
MTV is just as blowing and blowing it up to the next level.
And to the point,
man,
when they,
they,
they would do like the top 10 and it was like,
other than like a Paula Abdul and a Janet Jackson,
Michael Jackson,
like they,
they could break in,
um,
George,
Michael,
those people come.
But the rest of it was all pretty much hair metal if video's not civil or
pedestrian,
but safe in our opinion and completely produced in just the machine.
So what would you watch?
Was there someone,
was there a cool MTV out there that you are watching or we would go dig out,
which was,
you know,
Eric and Perry,
which are almost 10 years older than me and Dave,
they would help us realize the importance of joy division and Bauhaus in new
order,
an echo and Susie,
do you know,
I'm just discovering joy division now almost 40 years later.
That kind of simple storytelling.
Yeah cause me and Navarro,
we're about van Halen and we wanted to show off.
They wanted to tell a story like those guys and cinematic set a scene and just
tell the led the lyrics speak and of course me and they were still 18 whatnot.
We can play watch this and that's what the world needed.
The metal,
that's what la needed went global,
but it was the end of metal and a punk.
You know,
even the chilies and fishbone had records out and our very first tunes before
ritual,
dare I say influenced La funk idiots rule the pigs and Zan do too.
It was a chilly pad.
Could have been with the chili peppers show or a fish show.
And then we started to find our storytelling and our,
and I think our best moment back then was then she did on ritual.
When the lyric,
like I'm saying,
the lyric doesn't go four times and the music doesn't go three times behind it.
It's just that
concisely,
that album,
I learned how to meditate.
I swear to God,
I used to put it on the liftoff.
Yeah.
And I would put it in,
I would put it,
uh,
and I was really,
it was like the first time in my life I was realizing that I was fucked up cause
I look like Ron Howard,
my family looked like the Brady bunch.
We went to church every week and I thought,
hey,
you know,
I got this off when I was a fucking,
I went to work,
I was a good worker and all that.
And it wasn't until,
uh,
that way,
that's that weird thing.
I was running around 2122.
And that's right when you're supposed to be done with college.
You're supposed to know what you want.
You're on your way to your dream or whatever.
Put everything else behind you.
Move on.
Yeah.
And I felt I was just sorta like floating,
like what the fuck?
Like that whole part of my life has done,
college just went by.
I'm still a freshman basically.
Now what,
what the fuck am I doing?
And um,
I don't know.
That's my issue started coming up so well,
the,
the ritual record,
even though it was the end of the band was the,
this,
what you're hearing is us on tour and shaving all the parts and playing them
live and becoming an emotional organism.
And that's the documentation of what we sounded like.
And it was,
if we had a great manager,
he would have said,
take a year off.
I see a future.
Right.
We had a good manager just so you guys are gonna break up,
break up.
He wanted what was,
now we didn't give it to him,
so we didn't have any guidance.
But infectious came immediately.
I was in Hawaii.
Those guys showed up.
But Robert and Trey,
you know,
arbitrary heal and Mike Mirror,
they're going on tour the Ozzy in two weeks.
I'm in a new band.
So I didn't even think it was the wrong choice to break up.
But why with something so beautiful and colorful,
just call quits.
No,
take a break.
And maybe you know,
like any hot relationship,
maybe take a break and then maybe see if it's,
it's still worthy but we didn't have any.
Yeah,
little space.
And then they have a date night and hey see if you still like each other.
I am so happy how the,
the porno for pyros sound became something that was different and we were able
to grow and we didn't.
I love and I love the uh,
the second album that's still one.
Uh,
was it take,
he shouldn't be God's earth.
Bali.
I loved that album,
that,
that making,
that record was using all the money Warner's gave us to travel,
write songs and then you just a little bit of money to record it.
I remember being all excited to watch Larry Sanders cause you guys were on and
you've put way you go in and we uh,
yeah we had it all set up to do pets and then we got up there.
That's going to be a boring,
let's do me hot.
And that was a little more,
you know,
little charge but the band itself was,
was based on what I was saying earlier that that rhythm and phrasing of Perry
and I wanted to bring,
we didn't want to try to get a guitar soloist like we had in Jane's the
greatest,
right?
So Peter was more of a songwriter on acoustic guitar 12 string and we were out
with songs and with bongos around the camp you,
you had like Bango six where you would normally have like rack toms because we
wrote the tunes,
Campfire style with Bongos and acoustic guitars when we went into the studio,
those sounds and frequencies needed to be there.
So I started to incorporate this hand drumming riding style into the drum kit
and make it a hybrid drum set.
So I'm not going to rely on beats.
So when you recorded that,
did you play with sticks?
So were you playing with your hands on hot rods and sticks?
Good question.
You know,
the hot rods or the kind of splinter drumstick that,
oh,
is that what that perfect thing quieter,
right?
Oh yeah.
And they kind of,
you know,
you can get into it still,
but you don't have to quite the attack and articulation.
A little bit of more of a spread.
But I,
the approach,
because the bass player Martine was from Holland and he grew up with music.
I couldn't reference any sabbath tune or,
and he's up like,
you know,
there's upland Tony,
he grew up in Holly,
he couldn't,
so that made it quite interesting,
you know,
as far as a rhythm section,
we had nothing to kind of fall back on.
So it was all very fresh.
That's also interesting that someone could live in a part of the world that they
hadn't heard of.
Sabic exactly.
That's Kinda sorta didn't everybody's like hard drive.
It was an important like in America or Britain or the world.
That's interesting.
So right now you think you're doing right now is,
uh,
think experience.
That's right.
And this is like,
this is,
this really sounds cool.
So this is an la,
of course.
I'll look cool.
Shit seems to happen.
Your,
especially when I'm on the road,
when you miss it.
Yes.
When you're in West Virginia,
uh,
it's wisdom art park.
Yeah.
This is a great experience.
What we're doing is the saxophonist from pink Floyd and supertramp and Toto
Scott Page,
me and him hooked up many years ago and we've always thought,
wouldn't it be great to do pink Floyd music and our own way Norwood from
fishbone,
the Bass player,
Kenny Olson,
the guitar player from Kid Rock,
we all were kind of hanging out in this pink Floyd state of mind.
The Art Dome Wisdom opened up downtown and there were looking to fill the days.
Sometimes they've got a spin class,
sometimes they've got a,
you know,
a sound bath,
but it's always with these cool visuals.
So we brought the band in there and then you basically,
you can have either a folding seat,
a beanbag or a futon bed and the visuals above you.
It feels like you're a VR situation without the mask.
So even the band members experiencing what the audiences,
I'll see you laying down so when you look up at the dump,
so I was like wrap around.
Exactly.
I'm so fucking massive.
I'm still going.
Okay.
There's a couple of shows coming up.
You got to go.
There's other domes there that you can trip out on before the show and then the
big dome homes about 500 people and we play about an hour and a half of all
Floyd music with about 11 musicians to come and go with different singers.
You can look at the band,
but why everyone's tripping and oohing and Ahhing at the events are you looking
at,
I'm freaking out looking up and I've always wanted back in the day what it was
like not to be the cast member but the audience member during my Gig,
especially Jane's and Porno and shit was going on.
What's it like him there and I really am,
I'm just this,
we're seeing all the same thing.
Don't you find that once you've been like,
uh,
it took me a while but I'm about 27 years in now.
Okay.
Seasoned at this point.
And one of my favorite things to do is to actually walk into someplace big or
small,
whether it's going to be the show and is nothing on like I don't have to go to
work and school and I get to sit there and watch comedy or watch a band was a
gain experience.
Oh,
I love it.
I love that is my fuel,
my father to play more.
I love a big show even though sometimes musically you're disconnected and Faros
way over there and s you know Perry's hanging on a rope,
there's no visual moment,
but it's also some guide bungee jumping in a,
in a Ferris wheel and you're playing mountain song.
It,
this is,
what are they thinking?
I love that.
So I kind of get that experience.
I get to be an audience member.
What is that like when you're on your way up and it's like the first place is
you're playing,
it's almost the guys in your band are almost hitting your symbols and stuff that
tie and then all of a sudden it's just like,
Oh hey,
we finally in a place where there's a little bit of wrong,
I don't have to play like this.
I can actually have my kid,
you know it's true.
Well,
what we try to think that and when that gets big,
we tell the techs,
please set us up close as much as possible even though we need to be spread for
the people way out there because once you start losing that,
that intimate connection with the band,
the music does change.
It's kind of like being in a on a phone call and the room is quiet.
You're going to know everybody,
every,
every word you're thinking,
but if the room is loud and noisy,
you can like,
Oh hey,
do you know what?
Yeah.
Oh Hey man,
come on in and you know,
that's kind of how the big shows are.
You're like,
all right,
I'm with the guitar player.
Then I did that.
I haven't noticed something else is going on.
Right.
And then ever cause you concern like you know,
cause you always see a hair all like the Amy had four people,
four different personalities.
Absolutely.
At one point you're just playing and you like,
this is my best friend way the fuck over this standing in front of a fucking
fan.
He hasn't looked at me the whole show.
What are we doing?
Who are we?
What is,
where's the band?
And somebody like crowd surfing and it,
which is,
that's the weirdest thing about music.
It was then becomes the height and,
but then there's that,
that disconnect.
I mean I gotta think about Youtue and the chilies and Metallica,
there's this connection they have with each other.
That is,
Eh,
it seems to be very well spreaded in tight,
you know,
and the,
even though even stand close to each other on stage or they go satellite stage,
a small little stage off the big one to show that unit and to feel that unit
because I almost would feel like you guys would have to uh,
you know when you get as big as like that with a band that you would almost have
to schedule together time so you don't lose what got you there.
The one thing that's great about always with chains,
we have a backstage jam room and that is a smaller instrument is a small amp,
small kit,
little pa and we go back there and play our favorites plus the tunes maybe to
warm up.
Maybe tunes will be on stage.
I might possibly not,
maybe a friend will come and sing with us.
Those moments,
right are the moments memories of 1986 we wrote the tunes on Santa Monica and
vine.
Now those early days we shared a rehearsal place BulletBoys,
fishbone,
GNR and Jains.
And after you rehearse,
you put your gear in the corner and then you bring it back the next day.
And I remember,
you know the bullet boys got a record deal and all of a sudden they had nuclear,
oh shit.
Yeah.
Then Benji and I got big,
their ship moved out and they got their own room,
you know,
but you could see progress,
and again it's possible.
No,
but then that's that,
that,
that panic thing.
Like as a comic you start looking,
well that guy,
he started two weeks after I did,
he's moving and he's up there.
I like,
I must be doing something wrong.
So you actually sharing this space with people who are playing the music that
people were saying,
this is it.
And you still had that,
that thing we did.
The other guys like gene error,
bullet boys.
Were they listening to what you were doing?
I'm tied with Jimmy.
Dan to the drummer from the boys,
a bullet boys.
And he said he was recognizing what was happening.
He was not only feeling the sound was becoming redundant,
that was happening.
What's next?
But also the precision and the technique,
the technical plane was being lost in that type of metal music.
And so we were trying to bring back our love of rush,
you know genesis.
Yes.
You know,
there was like,
Whoa,
listen to what these cats are playing.
Even though there's a story we need to tell were from Hollywood and somethings
going to and mirror the lyrics of the mirror.
You know what I was thinking that was Saint Oh buddy of mine the other night.
Like in everybody like ragging on discos,
like a big thing.
Everybody is like the worst fucking music ever.
I will say the heavy metal ballad are some of the worst songs.
There's a few good ones scored me and it's just a fucked everybody.
I mean the Scorps did one big one lady lady something or about what it,
what about the,
you know,
the Berlin Wall?
I can't recall,
but I couldn't remember who was home sweet home,
which that that's not one of the worst ones.
But there are some out there,
the bands that became derivative,
derivative derivative of a motley crew and yeah.
Yeah.
And then they,
that was,
they had to do that.
Now remember Keith Moon,
they said,
Keith,
when did you stop destroying the drums?
It's somehow stopped though.
You didn't notice,
but they stopped for this,
you know,
and he said when it was in the set list of song number seven,
destroying the drawn,
she had to do it.
They were done.
Act like you're upset at your,
at your,
uh,
your drum kit here.
Oh my God.
A 24 inch bass drum head with a nothing shocking artwork.
Right.
We got to take a picture of this together afterwards.
Everybody can see it.
You know,
you would love it.
Especially because you love art and music and you play drums.
There it is.
That thing's been on the drum head and on the drums on tour,
but we never poke a hole in it.
We quit the mic mountain on the inside cause I can't take this.
You asked.
No,
are you kidding?
It's a gift.
It's a gift to you because you low enough.
This is going up and my drum room dude,
you got it man.
What you do for music and art.
And I was,
uh,
I don't know if you've seen my act lately.
I don't know if I'm doing all of that.
Well,
he said it was a good thing.
I inspire you to go to a different direction.
Like my act is basically like a heavy metal ballad and I'm sending it under
inspiring other comics to go into a different direction.
Well,
my advice to anybody trying to,
to be a drummer or a musician,
of course it's technique,
but don't look for that pat on the back because that's a bore you want to piss
people off.
My actual goal is a drummer is to think of my three favorite artists.
They're the big ones,
seven to Delhi because he can paint like Rembrandt,
but he doesn't,
he puts a fucking rooster come out of the head.
It looks real.
You look closely,
it's broken.
And then there's MC Escher with the black duck and the white duck and the
rhythms and just continue the patterns.
I,
that's a drumming pattern in,
in art.
So this is way beyond me.
And then there's Pollock.
He spent his whole life like all of us trying to become,
he uses a brush and I wanted it to be behind them.
And then he said he threw the paint and that's what I thought.
That's what do I do when they give me a rock riff?
I'm going to do Baba tune geology.
Twingy
no,
I don't be on me dude.
I hate when I go to museums,
they make me feel dumb.
So I go there and I'm just like,
I don't get everybody's doing,
but my
wife is gradually trying to get me to be a little more uh,
well if the rhythm is so visual and of course even our bodies,
whatever your digestive rhythm is or your sleep rhythm,
you're,
whenever it is,
we all have a rhythm that makes us feel
well,
what are you,
what are you thinking when you're playing?
Because you always have like the biggest smile and it's like even if I didn't
play drums,
I'd be watching you guys having the time of his life.
I am.
That is the,
I can't do wrong.
Of course I can drop the stick or pull off something.
The Ego can strike you if you think too much,
like you got it right,
but I can't do wrong as far as I remember seeing gene Krupa played drums in a,
in a movie and they showed a guy conservative couple.
He was tapping his hand and the wife's like,
ah,
but they went to her foot.
She was tapping her foot.
Right.
That's what drums make me feel like I cannot lose.
I'm going to make people feel good and life fucking sucks.
Everything sucks or the world and moves the shit.
What is good is like my kid,
my wife and the drums and I,
there's something fun.
I remember my friends came by and bought a cow bell and they learned how to play
beautiful girl or a dance the night away.
Van Halen
and my friend's like Colin Jesus.
Then it was like,
you know,
this is exciting.
It's hitting a home run for my friends or strangers,
but it's,
it is.
I got,
you know,
I got to compliment you hear as far as like the fact that your whole career,
you've always been going towards the art thing and then some out pays off,
which is very rare because usually when you go that route,
it's painful.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
You're on the,
you're on the futon train is,
is usually where it,
where you're at,
but you've,
you've always,
and then you will arrive with Jane's and then you still were able to go back to
be like,
no,
this,
this feels good.
Let's,
let's put the Bongos in here.
Let's do that.
Which was what nobody was doing that and what,
um,
I've experienced this in,
in my career where I've gotten something and then I think of my next move on my
next moves thinking,
well,
I'm here.
I got to try to stay here or go to that next thing in.
And it's like,
uh,
you know,
a two week or a two month hangover.
Absolutely.
The rush of that thing.
And you've gotta be like,
we're not,
wait a minute.
Why did I,
what was the reason I got into this business?
What did I want to do?
So then it always goes back to going down to the clubs,
trying out a new bid,
having making another comic laugh and have them come come to you going to do
this something there and then fee and then driving home,
you know,
did a guest spot made no fucking money driving home,
excited going and then you're thinking and you're talking to yourself and people
looking at you at red lights and you don't give a fuck all night.
I'm going to go down.
That's the organic fuel that I still get.
I love those drum events and competitions even though the gospel chops of
invaded.
But you see everybody must've rehearsed for the last two months.
You see even see the pros that have a 40 minute performance they you can tell,
you can tell if you,
I mean I would think cause those kids,
that's such a huge shot,
that guitar center thing kind of put it to sleep now.
But you're right,
it was big.
It helped.
No,
I mean I still follow those and like a couple,
two or three drummers that I became huge fans and watching their bands and
stuff.
And um,
but it's good for this.
It's good for the scene.
It's good for drummers.
Yeah.
I those competitions,
like,
you know,
it makes a pros and amateurs tuneup,
practice more,
practice more.
That's it.
Let me,
I,
I tried to ask,
uh,
if I remember when I get with somebody of your talent level.
So the big thing you're always chasing,
no matter what you're doing,
is kind of getting into a zone where it's like you're not even thinking and it's
just flowing through you.
And if any,
do you have a way of like,
um,
if you feeling like I'm in my head and I'm thinking about,
and now I'm hitting the bass drum and I,
but do you have any mental exercise that you do to a,
Steve,
get Outta your fucking head.
You're in New Jersey right now.
Look at that person over there.
Take him like do you have any tricks to get you out of the worst artistics
space,
which is sitting between your fucking ears?
Absolutely.
Thinking what are you doing?
I mean there is so many ways.
As a drummer I can sit and practice and I'm alone a lot and there's a lot of
alone time and a lot of my musician friends have a different schedule and not a
lot of my musician friends have a job.
What am I going to do in my day?
I don't want to be faster.
I just want to be more alert and be able to pull things off that I'm thinking
with the technique.
But there is the time I'm sitting at the drum kit and I'm like,
this is 100% meat.
This is so boring.
Right.
Do a one 80 what exactly don't exactly what you wouldn't play.
Go against your instinct and force it over and over and see what happens.
Yeah.
And so I have to force myself to,
it's a,
you know,
get away from the endurance and the technique and the speed and the flow.
What's,
what's going to Zap me creatively?
How the heck am I going to wake up creatively and come up with something new?
Is it putting a Bango in front of me that would help,
but that's not going to do it.
I've got to hit the thing.
How do you do this on tour?
You're on tour.
You're 40 fucking dates in.
You want to go home,
you miss your wife and kid and your lights go down.
Crowd's going crazy,
and you're thinking like,
oh Jesus,
I would love to go back and take a fucking nap.
What do you do then?
I'm a complete believer in waking up and exploring cities,
towns,
people,
the best sandwich shop,
the best record shop,
the fountain where the punks hangout and then bring that to the Gig.
Even feed it to the singer.
Hey,
they got a fountain down on Third I was at the fountain on the other place.
Goes nuts.
That's a turnoff for everybody.
I love that.
And I,
and I put that into my plane,
right?
And I,
I tried to,
okay,
why am I here?
Only play for 75 minutes.
This is a whole day away from home or whatever,
you know,
I'm missing.
And so I do try to fuel it with that.
I'm fucking lucky.
I'm out of town.
I'm,
I got a gig tonight.
Let's go enjoy.
I as a drummer,
the recognition,
you don't get much of it.
You walk around town.
I don't have anybody bothered me.
I don't know if that would be an issue,
but I can imagine if you don't want to be recognized and you want that world to
get out there,
it could be a bummer.
Right.
Fucking really famous.
You know,
like,
you know what,
I always wish,
I always wish they had that thing from star trek going be at home with your wife
and kid and kissed him.
I'm going to work.
And then they just,
you just big beam beam you'd have,
Toronto is something,
I mean,
how many times I want to clone to send them off to do the Gig.
Yeah.
And that's why I like Ag.
That's always a scary thought because then I sit there going,
who the fuck am I to be?
Not,
you know,
enjoying this right now.
But then it's like,
oh that,
well,
that's what makes human beings move forward is you get bored.
Exactly.
We cannot just be there and just go,
this is perfect.
I'm going to die over and over.
You know what I do is I just,
I go out and,
uh,
I try and just walk out and not say anything for my act.
This is how I get myself out of my head.
And then if that's not happening,
even when I go into my joke,
what I start to do is I just try to tag it with different lines and blah,
blah,
blah.
You don't be like the music music equivalent be improvin whatever like musical
phrase it is,
and let's blow that out.
It's usually takes 92nd now it's going to take two minutes and 10 seconds.
But just,
just the fact and those last 40 seconds that it's something that I hadn't said
before,
even if it sucks,
even if I'm eating shit,
it's just like,
oh,
I'm bombing in Columbus,
Ohio is where I am right now.
These people don't feel like they're getting their money's worth.
And then that gets the adrenaline going.
So I learned over the years because I used to not know how to get out of that
and I would spend weeks or possibly months and then you get into like writer's
block and I had to like figure out like how my brain works.
Like it works in a very straight line where like if I introduce yourself,
well if I,
like if I thought about a show,
I said three things that I liked and if I said one that I said early in the show
and then one of the middle of one,
the end,
if the first one I thought about was in the middle,
that's where the tape starts and everything before it gets erased.
Gotcha.
It's like,
all right,
I don't know what the fuck that is,
but that's how my brain works.
So I have to,
um,
I've kind of learned like I don't tape shows and when I say something and I'm
trying to remember,
I can't,
I just,
I let it go.
And Michael,
that's,
that's how it was said.
I learned that from watching you guys.
It was just like,
hey,
that's how the song came out that night.
That's the fill I played.
That's the thing,
the guy saying you don't have,
everything isn't so fucking precious,
precious.
And there's also a sense of humor to it.
And that's what me and Navarro in Perry playing the chain song so many times
with different bass players.
We have to duff mckagan and we had everything up Chris and flee and we kind of
play with the arrangement.
Perry might just not sing the first and dance around and Clayton,
it's playful and you got the no,
it's just,
you know,
this is,
that's
a serious man.
It's a song.
But if you're in the moment that makes it fun and I'll do something to like make
my tech laugh or for Navarro or we'll do something backstage prior to the show,
have an Halan ref and then Dave will pull it out during the Gig and look at me.
That's fucking so cool.
It's kind of,
that's so cool.
He's a powerful force that they'll,
people are enjoying it at the same time.
There's an inner inside show within the show.
Yeah,
that is so fucking cool.
What are the dates of this?
This uh,
the first weekend of April and the last weekend of April.
It,
that wisdom art park.
All right,
so the first two weekends in here because I'm going and I'm actually going to
buy tickets before first weekend and last weekend.
Oh,
first Friday and Saturday.
All right.
So I have to go to the first weekend because I'm out of town the last weekend
and I'm going to fucking get these tickets before this thing hits because I want
to go see that.
I want to be fucking laying on my back listening.
It's the next level experience and I'm going with the beanbag too.
Can I request that the,
I'll make sure you have the bag.
I had my nine year old come and he has brought like three or four friends and
they were,
the other room's got a VR mask and one room is made of mirrors and light and
they were just exploring everything.
Right.
And it's so cool because now my music means more than just a,
he's a drummer.
They can realize and,
and his friends that it's an experience.
I'm just a slice of it,
but I want them to share this new technology because it's there and you know,
we can't ignore it and it's,
the Ai is here,
but I want to use it as entertainment.
But of course there's other ways that they should think.
It's cool that you play drums.
He loves it.
Man.
That's awesome.
You know,
sit there.
usually they get to the teenage years.
It's like,
Oh my God,
dad out,
he's dying being a rock star and he's nine.
He's got time.
Oh,
that's so cool.
Well,
um,
I don't know.
What else did I want to talk about here?
Oh,
you got a,
what do I got down here?
Oh,
I wanted to talk to you about the,
uh,
when did you start playing barefoot?
This is what I'm going deep.
Let's go.
People who aren't like drummers are listen,
like what?
They've got home from school,
1213 shoes and socks off that and then play drums till about five or six.
So I think that's just the natural taking the shoes and socks off at home.
And I play heels up and I play with the balls of my foot and my toes and I move
up and down the pedal so there's no comfort zone with the,
for the shoe on.
I get cramps in my toes going like a snail in there.
It's like it's not working right.
But uh,
there is something to say about the,
the feeling of an extra weight of a shoe.
And I definitely get a different sound when I have a shoe on and maybe there's a
little more beef behind it.
I was going to ask you if like you're at a club and I was Steven's,
hey,
come in and sit in.
You don't say hang on a second,
Mr. Rogers and take off your shoes and socks.
It's awful.
No,
I don't.
I'll use what they guide.
But if when I get comfortable behind my kid,
I'd prefer to be in a pair of shorts and nothing else.
And play.
Do you still have the kit that you played on ritual?
Do you still have it?
What kind of drum kit was it?
That was wasn't my 1980 or 79 Ludwig.
That was a Ludwig and then on ritual,
while that would doing ritual,
we used some of my brand new Dwu kit as well,
which was just weeks old,
but there was a tour that we just finished using the same drums over and over.
So you have that feeling,
and this is funny,
when Jane's addiction got our first 10 [inaudible],
we go,
let's go buy a new gear.
Navarro played Marshall's.
He went and got Mesa Boogie Bass player played an peg.
He got trace Elliot.
I had cracked Zildjian's.
I went and got pasty.
We went to rehearsal.
Sounded horrible.
Where was our sound?
It just,
we just bought a bunch of new gear,
just put it in the corner.
It was a waste of money.
We got our old shit back.
Oh no,
because that was how we sounded.
We needed,
we need to go by gathering.
Isn't that funny?
Like longing for this other stuff and you already had it.
We had what we needed man.
And I remember just putting all this shit in the corner.
He's got,
Oh while there was 10 k know.
Huh?
What is,
you also did a project with one of the players from all the strokes,
right?
That's right.
Nikolai the base
player and I have a base,
we have a band called the summer moon and we just did it maybe about 1530 shows
opening for Guinea Harrison.
And it's such a cool community of young,
thoughtful musicians,
creative people that are hungry to change and try new ideas onstage backstage in
this,
in the studio.
Is that a,
is that a new project that you're working with?
Like the album's coming out on the moon?
We did an EPA about the,
about a year ago and there's another eep common right now.
Cause that ban the strokes was a band that I was like,
I was like officially like old because I was freaking out and I was just like,
I don't know who anybody is.
Kids.
So what is that name a kid?
And I was looking at him going like,
Oh my God,
I'm like almost like 15 1215 years older than them.
And,
but that's another thing,
like I have to go back.
All the music that I missed when I was growing up,
I had to go back and start listening to that.
And then there was the shit that I missed in the 90 especially hip hop and all
that stype of stuff that I missed.
And then now I'm kind of getting into the two thousands and it just like just
someone like 20 years too late for those guys.
So I,
uh,
I dunno this shit,
there's so much shit that to try and listen to.
So,
but you know what I loved at the end of the eighties,
early nineties was the sound of the drummer.
He had something to say,
Primus and Soundgarden and tool and Earl,
the pearl jam and every drummer had something different than the other.
And they think the metal days,
you're talking about every drummer wanted to be t Lee and the,
you know,
they just,
it wasn't happening,
but it was a chance now to be yourself.
And if things change,
again,
it comes in waves.
You know,
that creative flow from the rhythm section.
Have you seen the Motley Crue movie yet?
The Darrell man,
I can't wait.
Oh,
it's so good.
It's so,
it's so like it's just,
it's perfect motley crew.
It's just awesome.
Ridiculous.
Just total and true.
True.
Yeah.
Cause somebody from the La Times gave one of them shit going like,
you know,
cause they showed like all the groupies that they were banging and everything we
thing and they were just like,
just total lies the time you need to blah blah,
blah blah.
I think it was Tommy,
he was just like,
well I mean it happened.
I mean,
do you want us to like rewrite history?
What are we doing here?
And a story we're telling the story.
Yeah.
It was a really,
uh,
yeah,
it was lie plastic motley crew and it was dark.
But in the end it overall,
it was like fun.
Yeah.
It was just,
and you walked out like,
dude,
what the fuck was that?
Like classic Motley show.
I just,
I can't say enough good things about,
uh,
I always fuck up that expression.
It's just fucking awesome.
I just loved it.
I loved it.
Well,
I got to play with Tommy.
We had methods,
may mayhem,
double drummer,
and we sat right next to each other and I took the floor Tom out and that's
where his high hat was.
That's how close.
Oh Wow.
And then he's saying you play guitar while I drummed in,
then he joined me and let me tell you,
I mean did the rehearsals were the highlights because he had two hours of me and
him,
the band for hours and then they would split.
He's like Perkins being you going all night.
It's t lead double drummer.
Yeah.
It was just,
I was just looking at his bad ass.
He is,
and I was just listening to that album that the one that was just called Motley
crew where they had that,
that other sets,
right.
Dude,
that album is so fucking underrated.
There's like it,
first of all,
they put out an hour and you can see what they were doing.
It's like,
oh,
we got a new singer,
we got to go hard.
It's,
I think it's Tommie's best drumming and mixed fire,
mixed best fucking riffs.
And that singer was just,
it was,
uh,
was incredible.
And I was listening to,
I put it on,
it was at the gym.
It's like an hour long.
It was kind of perfect.
And I was like,
wow,
I slept on this album.
I knew hooligans holidays.
I was just being a stupid eighties kids.
Like there's no Vince Neil,
I'm not going to give you some fucking chance like that.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's,
uh,
for any motley fans out there,
don't sleep on that album.
Obviously.
All the other ones everybody knows about.
So,
um,
all right,
we'll do it.
I can't,
I don't know,
man.
I can't believe I'm sitting here talking to you and this,
this,
I'm going to cherish joy the head.
Oh my God,
this thing is,
I'm going to,
yeah,
that's going right on the,
uh,
right on the wall.
My,
my,
my little drum area just became 10 times cooler and thank you so much for all
the fucking great music.
Thanks bill.
And being a real artist and always going for some different cause.
I love everything you do and I'm going to see the first weekend in April.
All right,
Stephen Perkins,
everybody check them out.
I think Floyd at the wisdom art park here in La and a and that's it meant
everybody.
There'll be a little bit of music here and then another half hour of a greatest
hits from the Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Have a great weekend.
All right,
a couple of reads here.
it's butcher blocks.
Everybody put your blocks,
pitcher,
blah,
butcher box.
Fuck.
This month,
this month,
my God butcher box is offering.
I said this month is offering finally
ground beef that's clean and delicious and is taken from the most flavorful
sections of the animal.
The beef consists of trimmings from the Sirloin and chunk oh chuck,
sorry.
Which makes it so versatile.
It cooks fast,
so it's perfect for quick weeknight dinners right now.
New members.
We'll get two pounds of this delicious ground beef for free and every box for
the life of your subscription.
This was butcher box is most popular offer last year and they're bringing it
back for a limited time only cook with the peace of mind of knowing you are
eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with the leads at least eight to 11 pounds of meats,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals unless a your gluttonous and then
it's probably like five.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box custom box that lets you choose your own cuts.
Um,
my favorite cut is of course you all know my favorite media.
See the heritage breed pork most delicious pork chop I've ever had.
It's,
it's early in the morning.
I don't know why I can't fucking talk for $20 off your first box and two pounds
of free ground beef in every box for the life of your subscription.
Go to butcher box.com/burr or and to enter the Promo Code burr that's butcher
box.com/burr or enter Promo Code Bar,
a local.
It is his fucking my book.
Eov brackets.
First round upsets.
The final four march madness is hay and it's time to bet with the best at my
bookie.
Would you rather sit at your office desk or call out sick and binge on Ncaa
Tournament Games and junk food?
Like that's even a choice.
Come on.
Sometimes it feels good to be bad,
especially when it's someone you trust,
whether it's with someone you trust and if you're looking for a place to get in
on all the acts and you can trust my bookie there,
they've been in business for years,
then they're growing like wildfire.
The best part is they pay out fast.
So when you call that 12 or five,
that 12 over five upset this year,
make sure to celebrate.
You'll be pocketing cold,
hard cash.
March madness is the most exciting action packed sporting event of the year.
Even grandmothers fill out a bracket.
Place your bets with my bookie.
Now before you miss out my book,
you will match your deposit with a 50% bonus.
Um,
use promo code bur bur are to activate the order.
Visit my bookie.
Dot.
Agee today.
You play,
you win,
you get paid only@mybookie.com or you lose.
You lose your job and you're out there and blowing somebody at a bus station.
Okay,
just,
just playing devil's advocate.
It's framed bridge everyone.
Um,
if you've been listening to this show,
you've heard me talk about frame bridge,
they make it super easy and affordable to frame your favorite things.
I'm seeking a frame.
A baseball season starts right framing the strike zone there from art prints and
posters to travel photos,
uh,
sitting on your phone.
Here's how it works.
Just go to frame bridge and upload your photo.
Or they'll send you packaging to safely mail in your physical pieces.
Preview your item online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free recommendations from their talented designers.
Instead of hundreds,
you'll pay at a framing store.
Their prices start at just $39 in all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first order of frame,
bridge.com when they use my code bur bur get started.
Freight to get started framing of photos,
uh,
or send the perfect gift for that.
For weddings,
birthdays,
and special gifts.
Go to frame bridge.com and use the Promo Code [inaudible].
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to frame bridge.com/ uh.promo Code weight frame,
bridge.com Promo Code [inaudible] fuck frame,
bitch.com Promo Code [inaudible].
All right,
it's quip.
One of the most important things we do for our health everyday is brushing our
teeth.
Goddamn right,
it is.
Death comes from the mouth.
Fucking bacteria goes India hat and the next thing you know,
you flip you face plant and is Spaghetti's like that.
Fetch fucking seven,
right?
Oh,
those spaghettios anyways.
Yet most of us don't do a properly quip is the best electric toothbrush created
by dentists and designers.
People brush too hard in some electric toothbrushes are too abrasive.
A builtin two minute timer plus every 30 seconds to remind you when to switch
sides.
You dope helping
help me.
It's so easy.
Even a more on kid brush,
his teeth,
health guy helping guide a fallen and even clean.
Why declutters your sink or cabinets and makes traveling with an electric
toothbrush easier.
Quip doesn't require a clunky charger and runs for three months on one charge.
I'm getting one of these brush heads are automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months for just five bucks.
Why three out of four of us use bristles that are old,
worn out and ineffective.
Quip is the one of was one of the first electric toothbrushes accepted by the
American dental association and as thousands of verified five star reviews.
Uh,
why do I love quip?
I'm,
I don't have one,
but the fact that I only have to charge it once every three months,
I'm,
I'm in love with it.
I'm going to have an affair.
I have to talk to my wife about this toothbrush and that's why I love quip and
why they're backed by over 20,000 dental professionals.
It's like three grand per state right now.
500 I don't know.
Fucking quip starts at just 25 bucks and you'll,
and if you go to get quip.com/bar right now,
you get your first refill pack for free with a quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack at GE,
Ti,
Q,
u I p.com/burr Jesus.
How many reads are there?
Ah,
it's dollar shave club.
Everybody.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everything has everything you need to look,
feel and your best and they never,
and you never have to go to the store.
That's because they deliver everything right to your front door and they keep
you fully stocked and what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting.
Ready for a date,
a graduation,
murdering your next door neighbor.
They have you covered head to toe for your hair,
skin,
and your face.
You name it.
They haven't.
And they have this new program where they automatically keep you stocked up on
products use.
You determine what you want when you want it to shows up right at your front
door.
You fat fuck from once a month to once every six months.
Plus they're handsome discount,
uh,
with their hands.
Some discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save it.
Right now,
dollar shave club has a bunch of startups sets.
You can just try it for five bucks like their oral care kit ladies and after
that,
uh,
the restock box ships regular sized products at regular prices.
Get your status set for just $5 now and dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar
shave club.com/burn right lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom,
five things business owners can count on from it.
Legal Zoom number one,
uno.
Ah,
reliability.
Over 2 million people have used legal zoom to start their businesses,
LLCs,s Corp's nonprofits,
dbhs and Morris and Morris and more.
You can use legal zoom to get started right away.
Numero dos,
the experience they had been helping all types of businesses for over 17 years.
You can count on Lou legal zoom to help with all the details.
Number three,
twice.
Trace helps.
I can't do all the way up to fucking five Kenny.
Helpful support.
They have the right people standing by ready for your questions all based on in
the u s number four quatro
[inaudible].
Uh,
legal advice.
Legals isn't a law firm,
but they have a network of independent attorneys licensed in all 50 states,
sank home.
They can review contracts,
contracts,
help with employment laws and advise you on many of the hurdles that pop up when
you're running a business.
And finally,
number five,
uh,
uno.
Dos,
tres quatro,
Cinco,
the dwell sac,
no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with upfront pricing and customer
reviews and a satisfaction guaranteed.
Check out legal zoom today to see if they can make life better for you and your
business.
And don't forget,
enter Burr at checkout,
but you are to save even more legalzoom where life meets legal legal zoom.com.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
The fuck is it?
March 28th,
2011.
Oh my God.
How is march already over
and like a lamb out like a lion?
Did the fucking goats see its shadow?
That's one of the great things about living in a desert.
You don't have to listen to that dumb shit when it comes to February and March.
You know when you live in the desert,
the desert area,
I don't have to deal with that shit.
What do you think's going to happen?
It's been so mild in the beginning of March.
Does that mean it's going to get temp temp to west towards the end?
I don't know.
There Sharon.
I don't know what's going to fucking happen.
All I know is that it's going to be 70 degrees out every day for the rest of my
life.
Provided I stay out here.
I'm speaking of the desert.
I a actually visited,
a friend of mine,
visited it at it,
um,
out in the desert buddy.
Mine is,
had,
uh,
at a baby girl.
Well,
he didn't have it.
His wife had it.
Who else?
Douche.
I'm sorry.
It's an old joke.
I'm get settled in here and getting settled in.
Let me get settled into the podcast before you start rolling your fucking eyes
at me.
And yet God damn cubicle.
All right.
Little Miss.
Ooh,
I'm going to get an office someday.
Is that what you think that,
that,
that cubicle represents?
Look at.
They already gave me half the walls and no ceiling.
I mean,
where else can you go from here some day?
I'll have a door.
Um,
I got news for Ya.
All right.
If you're in a cubicle right now,
why don't you fucking grow a Dick that includes the old ladies.
Get some fucking balls.
All right.
Take out a quarter.
And why don't you stick it in those plastic bolts that are holding the walls of
your cubicle?
Upper right?
I'm not saying take your fucking cubicle down.
Why don't you just loosen them up,
add a little chaos to the day so the next time your boss comes over like dead
Douche in that movie office going,
Yay,
I'm going to need you to,
yeah,
when he leans on that fucker,
maybe he'll fall backwards and smack his head off that all weather carpet,
you know that has a very thin layer of padding and then it's concrete and then
you could act like you're concerned.
I don't know what happened.
And as people sit there,
you know freaking out because the guy's eating his tongue at that point in the
middle of a fucking seizure.
You just,
you know,
subtly really tighten the bolts.
So then it looks like,
Hey,
maybe this,
you know,
there's no evidence of why this guy just fell over.
Maybe has health problems,
at which point his health insurance,
they're going to fucking drop him.
He'll then be seen as unstable by the company and guess what?
His fucking office is going to open up.
All right.
That's how you get a fucking office nowadays in corporate America.
Okay.
You think you're going to sit there with your nose to the fucking spreadsheets,
you know,
doing all that actuary horse shit,
trying to figure out how long the average person's prostate.
I had a fucking,
whatever the fuck you guys do out there.
If you live in Nebraska and you have four headed fleet from a fucking court
field,
you have an average lifespan of 67.8 years.
Nobody cares.
You know,
she amazes me about that shit.
That's somebody's passion,
like just sitting like the way I love comedy.
You know the way a serial killer loves murder.
There's somebody out there sitting in a cubicle just looking at figures and just
seriously has a song in their heart.
You know,
a little bit of Christmas in their eyes as they try to figure out how long the
average person in Japan is going to live.
Now that there's radioactivity in the ocean,
you know,
they want to get there first to predict the death day of somebody over there.
I got to met to that shit that's going on over there in Japan.
I told you about that last week,
but that's just fucking freaking me out.
Those poor people over there.
Uh,
you know,
and I'm telling you,
I,
considering I don't go to the Catholic church anymore,
I'm going to start going to the Church of fucking Ted Nugent.
I'm not going to start referring to myself as uncle bill and feel like as though
I'm rebelling against something.
But I definitely,
I definitely think I need to secure my perimeter.
Do you know my girl won't let me get a fucking water bubbler water bubbler,
not one of the a water cooler.
She just won't let me do it.
She's,
she's such a fucking broad.
I'm sitting there watching the disaster unfolding over there in Japan.
Go and look at these poor people.
They live on a fault line.
Just like us.
Look at the panic and fucking confusion.
When you take the average person who doesn't know how to live outside and you
force them to live outside,
they're walking around,
you know,
without a laptop and a cell phone.
Probably for the first time,
I'd say in 15 years,
but that's more American.
We're talking Japan here probably for the first time in 30 years over there,
you know,
with their fucking advancements.
And it's just like I'm looking at them like,
okay,
number first thing you fucking want.
Yeah,
you want some water when can go 30,
30 days without food.
Right.
But water,
you can only go three days.
So here I am going,
you know,
we've got a couple of fucking,
gallon jugs of Arrowhead in a,
that's not an advertisement.
There's no advertisement on this podcast yet.
Okay.
But I am subtly throwing it out there to arrowhead.
Let me just start mentioning products on my podcast.
You know,
I'm sitting here in my craftmatic adjustable bed.
Dude,
he's totally whoring himself out.
The fucking podcast sucks now.
Wow.
Fucking put your,
you put your fucking head down in your plastic desk right now.
All right.
Right there.
Fucking staples.
Shut your face.
Anyways,
so we got,
uh,
we got like two gallons of fucking water in our refrigerator and that's it.
Okay.
Those coolest man he got,
he got five gallon jugs.
So you get two of those.
You always have about,
you know,
roughly at least five gallons of water anywhere,
all the way up to like seven to nine.
Who the fuck knows,
right?
Well,
maybe you get lucky.
The earthquake hits when you got two full ones,
and then when everybody around you is dying of fucking thirsty and you're
sitting in there sipping your water,
you know,
sipping your water,
running your hands through your gold coins with the fucking nine millimeter
between your fucking legs,
you're going to,
you're going to feel,
okay.
See,
that's how Americans look at a disaster.
It's not let's all get together and try to fight through this.
I told you last week,
it's gangs in New York over here.
All right,
English people before you get on your fucking high horse,
if there was a fucking giant earthquake that affected all of Europe,
you're going to get,
you're going to help the French people out.
You're going to help out the Krauts,
[inaudible],
all those guys,
they're with their wooden shoes over there in Holland.
Fucking tap dancing along with a fucking cow or some shit.
Whatever they do over there smoking weed,
you're not going to help out.
You're not all right to shut your faces.
Anyways,
so this is what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about preparing yourself for a fucking disaster.
All right,
and what is my girl concerned about?
I just don't know where we're going to put it.
It just,
you need to measure it first.
We can't put it over there.
That doggie dishes there.
The doggie dish is going to float out the fucking windows,
you know?
No wait,
we're up on the second floor and on the hill.
We're on in the hill on a hill,
right?
We're going to be fine.
I'm further enough away from the fucking ocean.
I'll tell you,
if a tsunami hits me,
where the fuck I'm at,
I don't want to live.
You know what I mean?
Kevin Costner though.
Real Kevin Costner,
not even him playing his character in waterworld.
They'll real Kevin Costner.
We're probably float out of the Hollywood hills right past me.
That's when I take out my nine millimeter and I fucking aim it right at his
receding hairline.
You know,
I should fucking talk.
Right.
And I just fucking blow his brains out and I take his little raft,
you know,
there's going to be some half dress hot hot little whore on,
on the,
on the raft to right.
Can't have a fucking disaster movie unless there's a scantily clad whore in the
middle of it.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
that's what the fuck she is all about.
That's what the fuck she's all about.
She doesn't know where we're going to put it.
And I'm sitting there going,
well,
you know,
I could break down some of the shit in my office and she's just like water
poplar,
water cooler and an office that's just,
you know,
I was watching that fat con to went to jail for the stock shit the other day.
Never remember her name.
And uh,
what does it Mandy,
she's got that Goddamn bowl cut.
I know.
This one.
I'm going to scream it.
I'm going to tell you right now,
later on the podcast when I'm not thinking about it,
I'm going to remember it.
I can't fucking it.
I keep thinking Rhonda Shear.
I know it's not that.
What is your flubs is the name of the chick who fucking shows you how to make a
pie,
but for some reason doesn't do it.
She goes,
this is how you make the perfect Pumpkin Pie.
And then she calls in some immigrant to do it for on a cooking show.
How I keep having it.
Why don't we keep thinking Madeline?
She said fucking ship from Connecticut.
Self made woman.
I respect her.
You know,
I felt bad for her.
She was the Oswald's of Wall Street.
She was the patsy.
She's the one that went down.
They didn't get any of the bankers.
They just got her right knee.
She gets her pubes highlighted.
Do you think she has that kind of money?
Martha Stewart.
Bam.
I got it.
Uh,
you know,
you'd be having some money when you get your pubes dad baby.
Y'All ready?
Next for this next motherfucker come,
which is the stage is mother fucker representing day.
I'm sorry,
I had a flashback to some old shows.
Uh,
anyways,
he's speaking of survival.
Okay.
I drive a Prius,
you know,
so you know what I love about it.
Prius is,
it's not the gay his car on the road anymore because Nissan has come out with an
all electric car called the leaf.
Okay.
I challenge you to come up with a gay or name for a car.
All right?
And I'm not attacking the fucking homosexual assault for there.
As far as I can tell,
there's a lot of gay guys that could kick the living shit out of me and have
their way with me.
So the last thing I want to do is make someone mad at me who oddly may want to
fuck.
I'm just saying it's gay as in it's fucking lane.
Okay.
And all you fucking gay people can go fuck yourselves.
All right.
That's what words do.
They morph into other shit.
Gay use domain mean really happy.
The gay nineties the 1890s were known as the gay nineties that didn't mean there
was a bunch of guys out there blowing each other.
Right.
Just meant everybody was happy.
They were happy and gay.
Those are the gay and that old anxiety song.
The new year song may all equate,
ditch be forgotten about Duba okay,
Eh,
let's all be gay,
right?
Something like one of those fucking songs.
Uh,
is it in the birthday song?
The word gay is in something.
I don't know what it is.
It's a song that I hear like once a year and I'm like,
yeah,
that's funny.
That gay used to mean happy.
Now it means you want to dive on your girlfriend's muff
whilst you have a muff yourself.
You know,
isn't that kind of just greedy?
it sorta the biggest loser of sexuality to be gay.
You know,
I have a dick.
Oh,
I kicked you once is not enough.
You selfish can't you got to go have another one?
Jesus Christ.
He's fucking gluttonous gay people.
Um,
these,
why do the POC?
I tried to do a fucking podcast last night and it sucked.
I need a good night's sleep before I do a podcast cause I was driving out from
the dance here,
uh,
because my buddy had a,
a,
you know,
his wife had a baby,
a beautiful,
beautiful fucking baby girls.
And it's such a relief when you show up in the baby's gorgeous.
Isn't it such a fucking relief,
you know,
cause some of them when they come out,
obviously they're like a little bit early or they're a little weird looking.
Their fucking head hasn't fused together yet.
Right.
And they look like,
uh,
they look like an octopus.
Some of them,
if you chopped off four of its arms,
actually six of its arms and then you put two legs in place of the two arms.
Right.
Bill,
we get it.
We can do basic math.
Yeah.
You don't have,
it's got those little octopus heads and you've got to sit there.
Hey.
Wow.
Look at that.
Uh,
yeah.
Why don't you,
is there any way you can stick it back in front of the a couple of weeks,
you know,
Vellum thinks you've attacked in your podcast.
I draw the line at babies still yet.
Why do you draw the line of babies?
Huh?
Cause you can feel it kicking in your womb.
I am really just being crass on this one.
Um,
who gives a shit?
How far into this podcast are we?
Oh,
13 minutes,
halfway through the first period over halfway.
Speaking of how that you guys see the Bruins Bruins made the a just clenched a
playoff berth by finally beaten.
The fly is v Time I watch a Bruins flyers game they lose unless it's a playoff
series.
And then they just when the first three and then lose the next fucking four.
But as the first time I watch the Bruins flyers game in a long time and uh,
they actually want to God damn good team flyers have and the fucking rangers
scare the shit out of me with Henrik Lundqvist motherfuckers stop and
everything.
But I think Tim Thomas is a better goalie.
Uh,
and I think we know something.
We've oddly adjusted very well.
Uh,
once we trade it all Douche face there and he does have a Douche face.
Phil Kessel,
you guys watching the NFL network where for some reason when they say NHL
hockey,
they have to tap.
The guys do these stupid dramatic,
like they'll,
they're not facing the camera and then they turn around and they're all sweaty
and they this look on their face,
not happy,
not sad.
Just sort of staring intensely at that.
It's like I get it.
It's hockey.
It's an intense sport.
You know the guy couldn't towel off before this.
Is he sweating from being under the lights?
Am I really supposed to believe that he just skated over to the bench and you
were able to black out the entire arena and now he's staring at you?
Well some of them look cool.
Some of them look intimidated and some of them look okay.
But Phil Kessel,
he just looks like a Douche bag.
I don't understand it cause he's a fucking great player.
But you see his puffy baby fat cheeks when he turns around and he just looks
like the kid that you would cross check even if his fucking parents were
standing on the side,
you know,
if you play like street hockey,
then you try to play it off.
Oh I'm sorry.
And is he cried?
It would make you have a nice feeling,
right?
And your heart,
you know,
my,
the only psycho like that
wasn't there always one kid in your neighborhood.
You just love to see cry,
you know.
And was there anything better that when somebody else did it and you didn't do
it,
so you could actually sit there and laugh and enjoy the kid crying and he didn't
have to run away when his parents came running out of the house.
Does that scenario even exist anymore with you fucking
this new generation of fucking cons out there who spent their entire childhood
inside on the Internet and playing fucking video games?
You missed out.
You missed out back in the day when you used to play outside.
There was always one kid and he was fat or he was fucking weird looking.
So what you did was you picked on him.
Unless he was funny,
he realized,
okay,
I gotta be funny.
You know,
kind of like make,
when I was a kid,
I looked like opie with a little bit of Ralph mouth and I realized,
I realized this.
I'm like,
wow,
I'm the only one who has this fucking hair color in my neighborhood.
I look like a fucking freak.
I bet.
I bet to start fucking common with the jokes here.
I did and that's what I did.
I used to God sign a little Tuxedo and I would just start,
hey,
interesting happen thing happened Amea,
the middle of getting potty trained or whatever.
I would,
I would have jokes because uh,
yeah he used to get the shit kicked out of me.
What do you think that kick of ginger days?
It's something new.
I think we always haven't been picked on.
Um,
anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about here?
Well that's something that I get,
I've gotten a lot lately from people.
People think I don't understand the Internet,
which I think is absolutely hilarious.
Like this something to get it Kinda,
it is what it is,
you know what I mean?
It's like how don't I get it?
Cause I call you out when you do dumb shit.
You know,
I was on the Joe Rogan podcast,
uh,
this past week and a fucking amazing podcast.
I go there and Joe's like,
dude,
you know,
whatever time you want to come over,
blah,
blah.
And I said,
all right,
why don't we say 12 noon?
Cause I don't want to get stuck in rush.
Basically how it works out here in La is you got to schedule everything between
between 10 and two in the afternoon.
That,
anytime I haven't been any.
When do you want to meet?
Between 10 and two.
All right.
Buddy of mine,
Al Madrigal,
hilarious comedian.
Definitely check them out.
Al Madrigal,
he's the one who he told me to do that.
So I go 10 between 10 and two now.
I'm not going to go there at 10 in the fucking morning.
I said,
all right,
I'll go there at 12 noon.
So I'll do 12 noon.
I'll get out of there.
Two,
two 30 all avoid rush hour traffic.
Right.
And His fucking podcast is so much fun.
I think we did like a three and a half,
four hour fucking podcast.
You know,
it took us like a half an hour to settle in.
So we started at 1230,
you know,
he gave me this coconut water that was so fucking delicious.
I actually came home and immediately went on to Amazon in order to fucking case
of it.
12 pack is what I got.
You know,
alligator armed it.
Uh,
now cause I didn't want to get a case,
I just wouldn't want to deal with my girlfriend going first,
a water cooler and now a case of coconut water.
Where are we going to put the cereal?
I didn't want to deal with that,
so I only got the fucking 12 pack.
All right.
So anyways,
we start the podcast and we just have a great time.
Fucking went through the whole thing.
I definitely suggest you listen to it.
I of course don't have the link because I'm an asshole,
but just look up Joe Rogan podcast.
He gets like 250,000 hits a week.
Um,
so you'll definitely be able to hear it.
But in the end of the podcast,
I got in this huge fucking argument with his,
uh,
with his male assistant,
a tech guy,
whatever the fuck you call them,
the guy who sits there.
And uh,
you know,
it was constantly adjusting knobs on the mixer.
Um,
we've got an a stupid fucking argument about whether or not someone had the
right to take my podcast,
put it on a website that had advertising on it.
And I basically said they didn't,
you could,
you know,
I put my podcast out there,
it is free,
but it's still my intellectual property.
I give it away for free.
So you take it for free,
you can't take it and then start making money off it.
And there was a website that was,
had all these podcasts and they will,
they,
you know,
they got them all on one website,
hence a ton of people went to the website.
Why?
Because of the creation of the artists.
Their intellectual property was getting hits.
No one was going to the website to look at the fucking website with nothing on
it.
They were going there to listen to the podcast and on their homepage they had
advertising.
So all these podcasts,
we're getting eyeballs to go to the fucking website.
All right.
And they go there and they read advertising.
And that's how you sell advertising by the amount of fucking people you get to
your website.
So how you supposed to do that?
I supposed to contact the artists or the owner of the work and say,
listen,
we want to use the ship.
We're going to be selling advertising.
All right,
we'll take our cut.
You take your cut,
that's fine.
That's what the fuck he supposed to do.
You can't just take it and put it on your site and start making money off of it.
And for some reason he was saying it was my fault because technology existed for
them to do that.
So hilarious.
He completely ignored all the laws of intellectual property,
copyright laws,
fuck all that.
You know,
it's like,
you know,
if you steal somebody's car,
that's grand theft auto.
But if you go out and you go buy one of,
what do they call those?
Those little Jimmy things,
those slim Jims,
we can unlock the door to your car.
You know,
if you have one of those that you know,
it's not stealing.
It's the dumbest,
the stupidest fucking argument I've ever gotten into in my life.
I'm arguing what the actual law is and this guy is talking about technology,
but technology exists for me to do something illegal,
therefore it's not illegal.
Was fucking retarded.
And the only thing more retarded was the fact that I couldn't fucking tap out of
the argument.
I can't believe I never brought up.
Well Dude,
I actually called my lawyer who went to law school and majors in it with a focus
in entertainment law.
And not only did he tell me I was 100% right,
he actually said I could sue that website if I want it to,
which I'm not going to,
but that's how right I was.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I mean a laptop exists that's legal to buy in a laptop.
And what the technology of a laptop and a little bit of smarts,
I can break into your online bank account and take all your fucking money.
Does it mean that it's not illegal because laptops are legal?
I don't.
It was the dumbest fucking argument ever.
And it lasted for 45 minutes and of course it got a zillion hits.
Joe was telling me it got the most fucking responses.
All right,
and you're going to sit there and tell me I don't get the Internet.
I get it.
People like arguments,
they like arguments.
And they like stealing shit and not get and you know,
and not fucking paying for stuff and then acting like they don't understand what
you're talking about.
It goes right back to that all that stealing music that everybody did.
Remember that shit and all the artists got mad going just stealing our music and
every sake we nuts steal it.
Hit man was sharing files.
No,
we were stealing it.
Look what we did.
We destroyed and I say we because I was online.
Why?
Okay.
I was online wire for a good eight months before someone finally was just like,
dude,
we're stealing music.
How can we do that?
Then that's someone can steal your fucking comedy.
This is bullshit.
And I know a lot of you right now sit.
And they'd go,
well yeah,
you go,
you stalled music gift for someone ought to be able to steal your fucking
podcast and fucking avid.
Now two wrongs don't make a right.
Okay.
Just cause I go out and murder somebody doesn't mean somebody can come over and
murder somebody.
I know we're both going to get charged with murder.
All right.
I didn't say I was a perfect person to this people.
I think it shows what a big person I am,
that I can admit to some of my wrong doings in the past.
But anyways,
after fucking 10 years is still a music look,
look at the music business.
Okay.
It's over.
It's fucking over.
Steven Tyler is on,
on,
uh,
American idol talking to people who work at a fucking Cinnabon telling them that
they have good voices and that they have,
they're going to have some sort of career in,
in,
in a,
in a fucking
art that where the whole business model has been completely fucking destroyed.
You guys haven't noticed that shit.
Musicians are like in movies now.
They're doing everything but segging I saw there's a,
there's a new show out where Christina Aguilar as a judge,
the lead singer of Maroon five is a judge.
Some country singers,
a judge,
all these guys
who cook,
who used to be able to sell out the staple center.
It's the whole fucking thing.
It's over.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
did that even make sense?
I didn't know what the fuck my point was.
I can't sell it to staples center.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
But I was right in that argument and uh,
I actually,
I had a great
time this week because I didn't read one of the emails that was sent to me about
that stupid argument.
I would just see it,
Joe Rogan's podcast,
a RSS feed,
any of that shit.
I just deleted all of them.
It was fucking was fantastic.
Absolutely fantastic.
So I didn't have to read that and argue with strangers who don't understand the
laws.
So there you go.
I hope as some of that man,
you know,
I realized halfway through that is none of you,
most of you probably didn't even hear the fucking argument,
but you'll probably go to Joe Rogan's podcast to listen to it.
Won't you see that?
Look at me spreading the podcast love.
Uh,
all right with that,
with that running of the fucking mouth,
what do I have coming up here?
People this week I'm actually going to be,
um,
what am I going to be?
I'm in town this week.
I'm actually working on April 2nd.
I let me get the exact date here in case I screw this up.
The name of the show,
it was Kevin and beans,
April foolishness show.
They do it at the Gibson amphitheatre.
I did it last year and had yeah,
April 2nd.
I had an unbelievably great time and I'm absolutely loved doing doing this gig
because not only do I get to work with a bunch of comedians that I never get to
see anymore,
it's all a bunch of headliners.
Uh,
as far as the fuck and I can see of course I don't have any of the fucking
names.
Who the hell's on a Patton Oswalt's on it.
Jimmy Kimmel's on it.
I'm on it.
Kevin.
A beads,
I forget.
I can't remember what the lineup is.
Fucking,
I think Dana Gould might be on it.
I shouldn't name names here cause I don't know.
It's going to be awesome.
All these guys that I love watching him work are going to be on it at a and on
top of that to Gipsy Gibson,
MP theater is used to be called the universal amphitheater.
And that's the one where the blues brothers,
they,
when they recorded a briefcase full of blues with my favorite,
one of my favorite drummers of all time,
Steve Jordan.
Uh,
that's what they did it right there on that stage.
And they were opening for Steve Martin back when he wore the white suit with the
fucking air through his head.
I'm a geek for that type of shit.
Theater history.
I always try to find out and I sit there really Charlie Chaplin play played
here,
Buster Keaton like that dumb shit,
you know.
Um,
so anyways,
I'll be doing that on April 2nd and then,
uh,
what else do I got?
Oh,
I'm going to be in Maryland at the record theater for two shows on April 8th.
And then I'm going to be at the tower with the ANA in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania on April 9th.
And then later on that month I'm hitting two cities.
I haven't done stand up ever or in a longtime Milwaukee.
Never been there.
Going to be at the,
uh,
the,
the PAPP's theater in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin.
April 22nd.
On April 23rd,
I'll be at the Royal Oak Music Theater in Detroit,
Michigan.
I have not been there since I did,
uh,
the Chappelle show tour with Charlie Murphy and Donnell Rawlings.
And I think we did that.
We did that.
Went back in 2004.
So it's been seven years since I've been there.
So,
um,
so please come out to that.
And with that,
let's get on with the podcast questions for the week.
Where is it?
Oh,
did I not again,
open the fucking thing?
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
you call yourself a radio host or a podcast host.
Is that,
is that what you call me?
Uh,
is that what you call yourself,
Bill?
All right.
Open.
Fuck.
What can I talk about here?
What can I talk about?
Can I talk about how the Bruins raped the Montreal Canadiens seven to nothing?
Did you guys see that fucking game?
Absolutely raped them.
And,
uh,
I got to tell you they deserved every fucking second of that cause this still
bitching about that said Dana,
Ciara hit,
Ya know,
he finished his fucking check.
The problem was,
is that they still have that fucking bored,
that,
that piece of glass right there.
That's the problem.
The problem is the NHL have seen for years,
guys almost get their fucking heads taken off on that part of the ice.
What you should do is just somehow make that thing collapsible.
Move it away from the ice.
I don't know what the fuck to do,
but there's got to be okay if I can have a car that has a collapsible front end
of the engine is designed to go underneath me rather than into the,
into my fucking torso.
There's no way the Nhl can't have that.
I'll put the clip on there by the way,
on the [inaudible] podcast.com so you guys can see,
um,
see that hit,
I mean it was brutal because the guy fractured one of his vertebraes and uh,
so I felt bad about that.
But then they were talking about the severity of the guys concussion and it
turns out the fucking Douche went to the movies like three days later with this
allegedly severe concussion.
Gotta love Mark Recky for calling him out.
He was actually taking heat shower,
just saying.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't,
I think he exaggerated it.
Oh awesome.
Is that he did that,
you know,
already no one helped fucking sensitive.
They are up there.
This so fucking sensitive up there in Montreal.
It's not like Toronto.
Toronto's a fun God Damn City Montreal,
some of the most beautiful women you ever going to see in your life.
But the men are just so fucking sensitive.
They actually have the police looking into that hit somebody to think about
somebody got checked into the fucking boards.
Okay.
And unfortunately right with a glass starts,
you know,
or the glass in between the benches,
and that they want to like put one of the Bruins in jail for playing hockey.
You know,
I'll tell you what's funny is 10 years ago they weren't even been a penalty on
that play.
Um,
anyways,
so this is the deal.
Um,
the new email,
if you want to send me an email,
if you want to send me more fucking emails about,
uh,
agreeing or disagreeing with my argument on Joe Rogan,
he sent it to bill@thefmpodcast.com.
Please send me your underrated overrated lists.
Your advice,
if you have any questions,
your stories of revenge.
You know,
all the shit that we've been doing throughout the years here and ask,
speaking of overrated,
underrated,
uh,
I got one.
He for you as far as something being overrated.
You know,
what's overrated is outlets.
you don't,
when the broads get all excited,
we're going to the outlets they got in.
They got a fucking,
what a hell do they shop at?
They got to Jordan Mash at JC penny in a fire leads outlet to any of those
stores still exist or did Macy's just fucking buy up all of them,
you know,
whatever,
whatever the fuck they buy,
you know,
they got all those stories.
Oh my God,
it's going to be blah,
blah,
blah.
So you go in there as a guy going,
all right,
well maybe this won't cost me as much fucking money.
What do you want a pair of shoes,
sweetie?
Hey,
let's go to the outlet.
Sounds like a fucking,
you know,
sounds like a dream because when you really think about it,
it doesn't make any fucking sense.
Why is it so God damn cheap?
Why did they suddenly decide that they just didn't want them?
Is Make as much money on that shirt that that seven year olds sewed together in
the Philippines as they would in a mall.
What is it about the outlet,
you know,
if you use common sense,
you actually think,
well they're probably not marking them down as much as they think that as they
say they are and it's probably a bunch of shit that nobody wanted a bunch of
shit that didn't sell well at the malls and now they got to get fucking rid of
it.
Isn't that what it is?
That's been my experience.
You go to the,
they're overrated.
You go to an outlet.
And another thing that they liked doing is they like to say that the,
the actual retail price is about 30% more than it usually is.
And then they give you a 2% discount and you feel like you're getting like 32%
off.
You know,
cause people suck at math.
They'll do Adidas shell toes,
usually $126 now,
only 68
you know,
what a fuck are they,
168 or whatever to whatever the fucking number.
I just said the shell toes,
there's no arch support whatsoever.
It's the same fucking design that you've had for the last 40 fucking years.
So there's no,
there's no extra cost.
You don't have to hire somebody to design a new fucking sneaker,
right.
It's like a God damn Porsche to saint fucking design forever.
So whatever.
So we go there and she goes in,
she goes into Prada and I walk in and it,
it's still a fucking ridiculously expensive shoe.
I got so fucking mad at my girl at that thing I was telling us saying,
listen,
we're going out to the desert.
My buddy had a kid.
It's his first kid.
I want to go out there.
We that that's,
that's what it's supposed to be about.
But you know,
fucking women,
they can't just go out and go do,
stay.
Always got to get something.
Yeah.
If you notice that all you young studs out there banging away,
having one,
even if you have a one night stand with them,
they still try to get a tee shirt out of it.
He noticed that.
Can you feel how you teach it?
Then they just walk out with it.
The fucking weird.
They like,
they like serial killers.
Like they'd taken some sort of a trophy,
making a God damn food.
Who Doll give me,
you know,
it was one of the,
that was one of the,
uh,
one of the turning points is me as a single guy.
When I asked for the tee shirt back,
I started doing it and I a t shirt BEC and I,
I loved it because they didn't know what to cause.
They were pissed that they asked for it.
Then I asked for it,
but then they also didn't want to come off as some selfish cunt,
so then they had to take it off.
But there's just still
the conflicting emotions on their face.
Mad that you asked and then trying to play it off like they're not mad.
So you can see that they're actually a good girl who will jump on your Dick
after knowing you for about four and a half hours.
Right.
So anyways,
overrated outlets.
All right,
if fucking overrated.
Unless there's a bunch of stores that you like,
then it's just convenient.
That's the best you're going to get.
You know,
it's convenient while at least I don't have to walk through a food court and two
levels.
I like that.
It's just one level.
I do like that aspect of it.
But in general,
I don't see the fucking deals.
It's like,
how do you know how to,
like Vegas used to be mob run and now it's corporate corporate owned and
gradually the,
the $8 steak disappeared that you could get good,
you can get a steak for like six bucks,
you can anymore.
They turned them all into buff the buffets,
it's like the $20 buffet and then he got to go there and feel like,
you know,
you ate your money's worth.
So you go there and eat 10 times more than you normally would have and then you
fuck you,
you killing yourself,
you have each so much,
you start sweating.
You just have such a bizarre combination eating like rice and then a slice of
cake,
so fucking pancakes and then it's a piece of fish.
You know,
your body's just like,
dude,
what the fuck?
And you finish it off with like a pickle and then he's just sitting there,
right.
Look at it like that guy on man versus food.
You know,
when it gets down to the final two bites and he goes into what I call the
thinker pose,
you know where he sketched got his fist up against his skull.
Yeah.
It's the same thick outlets.
That's just,
it's,
it's the same hype that people used to say about Vegas.
People finally have stopped saying the,
the $6 steak bullshit.
Um,
all right,
so there you go.
That's overrated.
Underrated for the week.
Please keep sending those in people.
I love,
I love reading those things.
Um,
all right,
advice for this week.
These are,
I'm becoming just sort of the relationship advice person.
I don't know how this has happened considering I've,
uh,
I've never been married.
I don't have any kids,
you know,
so I don't know.
You know,
I'm basically the Steve de Burgh of relationships.
I'm somehow still in the league,
still in the game,
pulled in the clipboard,
but I haven't taken a fucking snap and like nine years.
Uh,
that's what I am standing on the sidelines as all you guys are getting married
and having kids just sitting here fucking wearing a headset.
All right,
but you guys want advice?
Here we go.
Um,
okay.
So I've been together with my girl for almost four years.
Got Married last September in 2010.
Uh,
these past weeks have been hell.
I'm a very honest person,
so I felt lately that me and my wife have not been close.
So I talked to my wife and told her how I felt and it,
and if we continue like this,
things can end up in divorce,
not things will he stressed,
can all capital,
can end up in divorce.
So we talked it over and all seemed okay.
A Sunday,
the 20th,
I asked her when she was coming home,
uh,
this was a 10,
20:00 PM.
She told me in the next 20 minutes,
I said,
okay,
cool.
I'll see you at home.
Uh,
I was driving home from a farther city,
so it took me longer to get home.
I get home at 12:00 AM and she is still not home.
So I call her and say,
please tell me if you're not going to come home on time.
So I,
so I know you're okay.
All right.
Sounds like a decent guy.
What does she do?
She starts yelling at him,
say,
uh,
I lost my place.
She starts yelling at me saying I was helping my damn friend stop being an
asshole.
Then she hung up.
Wow.
Uh,
she got home and yelled at me and everything and we argued.
She went to bed mad at me and I slept on the couch.
First Time I've ever done that in our relationship as par for the course.
You got married in September,
you go through the honeymoon phase right through the holidays and all of a
sudden Valentine's Day comes up.
That's more excitement now you were in the march is the real deal.
Okay.
If you can get along in March that that's that,
that's,
that's a good benchmark.
You know,
there's nothing going on in March.
There's no Valentine's Day.
There's no holidays.
Unless she has a birthday,
then it doesn't count.
They bill.
Why don't you shut the fuck up and read the rest of the email?
All right.
I will.
Next morning she leaves to work and I tell her,
I hope you hope you know me.
Sleeping on the couch is not a good thing.
And she goes,
well,
me not kissing you before I leave isn't a good thing either.
Jesus,
later on Monday,
she says,
I am not sleeping at home tonight.
I don't know if I want to be with you anymore.
Jesus Christ,
dude,
this is like fucking going vertical here.
She's in the space shuttle.
Um,
it's Friday now and all week she hasn't come home to me.
She won't even tell me where she is sleeping.
Barely answers my texts or calls.
She told me she isn't happy.
I don't treat her good.
She doesn't love me the way she used to,
but not once did she sit me down like a civil person and tell me to change.
She just up she up and just left.
Bill,
please tell me if you love someone and you're married,
would it be easy to just up and leave like that?
Uh,
leave that person with no warning and not giving the person a chance and less
she has another secret.
Oh Gee,
I think he suggesting that she might have another guy.
Uh,
she's filing for divorce soon,
Toby,
to keep everything.
She just wants her vehicle.
I'm dying inside and had been going crazy.
I cannot believe she would put me through this.
She said she's been thinking of this for two months but never sat me down so I
can work on being a better man while do two months is a long time.
When you only been married since September,
that's basically 20% of your marriage?
I would think so anyways.
He goes on to say she had nothing when we met.
I drove her to school every day and her parents did not care for her.
I did everything for her.
Why would she screw me like this?
The boy.
All right.
Um,
so what advice do you want here?
You want me to know why she would do this?
All right,
let's,
all right.
I'd have everything she said there.
I know all my listeners right now are pretty much convinced that she's out
fucking around on you and uh,
you know,
whose kid and hope they definitely,
I don't think would be wrong to think that,
but I think the fly in the ointment here is your description of her relationship
with her parents when you said that you drove her to school and did everything
for her yet her parents did not care for her.
Uh,
this is something that I noticed in my horrific dating past.
if you want to get somebody stable,
you have to come up with some sort of list of qualifications that they have to
pass or at least they have to pass most of them.
And one of the things,
if you want to get a well adjusted female,
mmm.
I'm not saying that they can't come from divorced,
but they have to have a good relationship with their parents.
Okay.
I found that to be a major red flag if I was on a date and I found out that the
person I was on a date with was not speaking to either their mother or their
father or would say,
my dad's a piece of shit or I fucking hate my mother or a,
we don't talk right there.
I'm telling you just run and the other direction because I don't know,
it just seeps into your fucking relationship and they do shit like this.
Cause I,
I'm thinking if you were doing every,
if she came from a household where her parents,
people who are supposed to love her unconditionally and they weren't doing shit
for her,
and then you come in there and you start doing everything for her,
just just out of never having that in our life on some level,
she's going to fall in love with you.
Even if she doesn't love you.
She loves you because you're giving her what her parents never gave,
gave her,
you know what I mean?
But that doesn't mean that she loves you.
And I think that that's,
and then you combine the fact that she had a fucked up relationship with your
parents where there was no love and that type of stuff.
She doesn't know what love is and can't communicate.
And when she's not feeling it,
she doesn't know how to get out of it like a fucking adult.
Hence she just leaves you.
And then because she's been searching for life,
love her entire fucking life,
rather than just going out on her fucking own
and just being alone and figuring out what she wants,
it kind of seems like she already has another guy and she's just swinging to
that dude,
uh,
gold right into another relationship.
So I'll tell you this,
this is what I would do.
I would consider myself fucking lucky that she did it this quick,
that you found out that you were married to a psycho and that she only wants her
fucking car.
All right?
So what I would do is give her her space.
Don't call her,
be civil,
work the fucking thing out,
sign the divorce papers,
let her get her fucking VW thing,
whatever the fuck she drives.
And let her and her baggage drive down to the Goddamn street.
All right?
Then you fucking,
I dunno.
Do Usual Shit.
Go to the gym.
Cry It out.
Go to the fucking gym.
All right.
Don't beat yourself up.
Don't start drinking.
Don't start becoming a fat.
Fuck.
All right.
Turn this shit around.
I'm telling you,
I don't come up with some healthy fucking way to deal with this shit.
Uh,
and don't do the Guy Shit where you're fucking white.
Knuckle your way through it and booze and go bang a fat chick.
Don't do that shit.
All right.
Fucking,
you know,
curl up in the fetal position and cry it out and just tell you,
keep telling yourself you're going to meet the right girl.
Do that.
But that one right there,
dude,
flush that one down the fucking toilet and kids,
it's a blessing.
It's a blessing.
Do.
Can you imagine if you had a kid with that fucking nightmare and for the rest of
your fucking life or at least for the next 18 goddamn years,
she's going to be in your fucking life and he got to listen to her opinions,
which would totally affect on some level your relationship with the next great
girl that you're going to meet.
The next girl is going to be a great girl cause you've been through the shit
with this cunt.
Trust me.
All right.
It's going to hurt.
Just fucking deal with it.
All right,
platoon,
take the pain.
All right.
Okay.
That's it.
Next one.
All right,
bill,
being in this girl now though,
now the relationship won't be bill me.
This girl is stationed overseas in the military.
Uh,
England.
Lucky enough due to our jobs,
we see each other a couple times a week for meetings and at the gym here on my
47 dilemmas.
This is a chance of being deployed and all of that business due to the war with
yogurt face in Libya.
The least of my worries.
Oh by the way,
did you see that fucking,
there was a couple of,
uh,
what does it,
Osher,
Beyonce and Mariah Carey actually did private new year's gigs for a,
for 1 million bucks.
Did New Year's gigs for Qaddafi's kids.
Can you fucking believe that?
How much fucking money do you mean need to make?
You know
you're going to take a gig where you going to go dance like a God damn fucking
clown for a mass murderers,
kids.
Then you take that fucking blood money.
Okay.
Stick it in your bank account.
Go Buy yourself some fucking glitter or whatever the hell you do when you're a
god damn singer by some more streamers to hang on your fucking mic stand.
And then when you get busted,
you try to play it off like you had no idea who Kadafi is
and what he's done.
Yeah.
You couldn't remember that he claimed he was behind the Pan Am bombing that
killed fellow Americans.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Okay.
I love that shit.
Where they tried to play it off like they had no idea.
Okay.
At the low level of entertainment that I'm at.
Anytime I do a private Gig,
they always tell you what the deal is.
I don't do private gigs anymore cause as Dane Cook,
classically put,
you feel like you're being rented.
That's the greatest way to describe how you feel when you do that kick.
See if you do want to see if you come out to a comedy club or a theater to see
my act,
you get my act and I get to say whatever I want,
but if you hire me to perform for your your company or a private fucking
Christmas party or some shit like that,
like I used to do those gigs,
uh,
there's always a list.
This is what they do.
Stay away from this and you either comply to the list or you just don't take the
Gig.
The last thing you do is say,
yeah,
no,
no problem.
Then you show up,
you do your Lenny Bruce fucking set and then walk away thinking you're a bad
ass.
You're not a bad ass.
You just an asshole if you're to go in there and curse.
And they wanted a clean comic.
You shouldn't taken the Gig.
They're hiring you private gig.
Right.
So buddy,
any either.
Anyways,
anytime I do a Gig,
if there's somebody in a fucking wheelchair,
if there's somebody mentally handicapped,
just that shit alone,
they'll poke their head in the back.
Hey,
just to let you know,
I don't know what jokes you do,
but this is the situation out there.
Just giving you the heads up so there's no problem.
There's no fucking way.
They're agents didn't say,
hey listen,
just to let you know you're performing for the children of a mass murderer.
This is how they feel about females over there.
Stay away from this.
You're able to gyrate this much during songs.
There was a whole fucking,
it's $1 million gig.
There's no way the agent lets the artists go in there not knowing who the fuck
they're performing for with performing to risking losing their commission on $1
million fucking Gig.
They're completely full of shit.
They're just giving the money back cause they got fucking caught.
I,
that's,
I think it's horrific.
Absolutely horrific.
So anyways,
back to the email.
Um,
so we've both been here being this broad for about six months.
Six months.
Okay.
Let me recap here.
Up until this point,
he sees his girl a couple of times a week.
All right?
Okay.
So the two dilemmas,
he works with the girl and also if he starts developing feelings at any point he
could get deployed to Olivia and she couldn't,
she might not or they might both.
And uh,
there'll be in separate parts of the country,
not fucking seen each other.
You know what I mean?
I don't fucking know.
I don't even have to say,
how the fuck can we start a third war?
We couldn't even afford one.
I really don't understand it.
All right,
let's continue here.
Uh,
we've both been here about six months and in that time,
everyone on the basis tried to get into this chick's pants.
She's a bomb shell for certain.
No one seems to get clothes.
How,
uh,
however I come to find out,
she's basically got dumped,
uh,
when she left her last base state side and has been cooped up in her house off
base trying to keep in touch with this dude.
She's rarely gone out and hasn't given date dating or whatever.
Much of a thought as far as I can wager.
Meanwhile,
I've been busy being miserable on my own as well as this,
as I had this stint with some cock Copchick over the winter and that basically
died about two to three weeks ago.
I started talking to this broad and spending time together regularly after work.
Nothing too seriously,
but apparently I can make her laugh.
I'm getting the notion that she's moving on from her old relationship.
Things seem to be going swimmingly.
I'm just not certain I can take the multiple risks and try to make a situation
out of this that will,
that wouldn't somehow end up in some sort of complete disaster.
I'm technically shitting where I eat and it's not like I could just quit this
job tomorrow.
I'm in the fucking military.
I'm trying to avoid certain disaster yet.
However,
I'm primed to be in the zone for a good,
real good looking piece and perhaps a healthy relationship thereafter.
I'm not sure how far,
how far to take this thing.
I'm conflicted.
I could a laugh.
Thanks for the podcast.
All right.
All right,
dude,
these are very fucking mature concerns.
MMM.
This is all up to you.
You got to figure out how you feel about this girl.
All right.
And then act accordingly.
If you want to fucking just bang this girl,
if you figure that out,
if you just want to bang this girl,
just be upfront and tell her that it's just a sex thing and she,
the goes for it or she does it.
Okay.
All right.
And if she goes for it and you bang her and then you don't call her afterwards
or you,
you know,
you're just still not having feelings for,
she can't get mad legitimately because you talked to her about it up front.
Of course there's always that,
you know,
18% psycho rule where she could be thinking,
well,
after he fucks me,
he's going to realize what a great person I am and then we'll have in a
relationship,
you know,
I would be a little bit nervous about this girl because she's still hanging onto
this other person.
So I don't know if she's just wounded or if she has an actual psycho.
So I will tell you this,
if you just have a fuck buddy relationship with her,
this is the key.
All right?
You have to space out the times when you bang her.
And when you bang her,
she can never spend the night.
You also can't watch a movie with her.
You can't do any sort of things that indicate you have some sort of relationship
beyond fucking all right?
And you have to bang her like the filthy fucking whore that she is.
That's basically how you sustain a fuck buddy relationship.
You fucking,
you leave and that's all you do.
We are fuck buddies.
We're not movie slash fuck buddies.
We are fuck buddies and that is it.
All right.
If she calls you up and asks you to come over there and help hang a fucking
picture,
you don't have time,
you can't fucking do it.
All right.
That's it.
You are,
you are a dick and that's it.
Now,
if you want to have a fucking relationship with her,
you've got to figure out if you really liked this girl,
at which point,
if you're mature enough,
you probably shouldn't try and fucker cause that will cloud everything.
Uh,
personally,
I've never been able to do that.
So good luck to you.
Those are your two options.
Fuck buddy relationship,
figuring out what the fuck you want to do and then act accordingly.
All right sir.
Good luck.
MMM.
Hey Bill.
Uh,
I'm going on my 11th hour of work today,
but up it up.
Oh,
I can read that part there.
Too many names here.
Okay.
Anyway,
spill.
I was fat and in a destructive relationship for most of college.
My confidence was just about ruined before I dumped the cut.
Uh,
and,
and I lost about 70 pounds.
Good for you.
See,
this guy did the right thing.
He got it for that guy.
With the first question.
This guy here,
he got out of a relationship.
All right?
And you look what happens.
It goes to the Jimmy drop 70 pounds.
Good for you.
Since then,
I've been with a lot of women and haven't had trouble meeting women.
I just know how to act confident.
I have fine,
but I do have trouble finding the line between asshole aggressiveness and simply
being confident.
Um,
all right,
well you're already banging a bunch of women.
You've lost 70 pounds.
It sounds like you're killing it.
So what,
what happened?
Did you piss off a couple of women?
What is your definition of asshole aggressiveness?
Or you talking to them and be like,
hey baby,
you just reach up and grab a titty.
You know,
this is the thing about being confident,
which you got to do is be confident about yourself,
but don't insult the woman,
don't I,
I've never liked that.
Like some guys do that what they do is they go up there and how they,
how they get the girl to be in a weak position is they sort of,
uh,
say things to her that,
that kind of makes her like insecure.
Um,
I dunno what,
what is a good example of that type of stuff?
Like I know you can just make some sort of comment about the clothes they're
wearing or just something or just be like,
oh,
what is an example?
I see.
I never did that.
Not because I'm a fucking great guy,
just because I,
I have a need to be liked so I could never go that way.
Um,
although I have found that like reacting to other hot girls walking around the
club with a lot of girls will somehow,
I don't know,
it's just weird thing with that,
like that sort of their competitiveness,
you know,
if he could just get into conversation about them,
about,
you know,
how hot you think some other girl is.
I know that sounds fucked,
but this has actually worked for me.
And then you just start talking about what you like in women,
what turns you on,
and then you steer the conversation into sex and then you're in there.
So I would say for me the difference between being an asshole aggressive is if I
actually say something mean,
uh,
I dunno.
I don't think should ever be mean to a girl to try to get her to fuck you.
I just think that's like a cowardly way into it.
But you know for you to be a cocky ass hole
and if they just,
if they say that they compliment you about how you look,
just be like,
yeah,
I know I'm a,
you know,
I'm a good looking guy.
I don't know what it is.
Women like me just along those fucking lights.
You just do that as,
as you sorta make it funny itself.
Then you show you have a sense of humor.
I would,
I would try to go that fucking route.
I don't know.
But once again,
you're talking to a guy,
looks like Ralph malf itself.
It probably works.
You know,
you guys,
maybe you guys can be assholes if you actually have some sort of pigment and
your hair.
Um,
all right,
let's plow ahead here.
A bill,
a friend of mine who I played in the bandwidth for over a year in high school,
lost his mother to a sudden Sart sudden heart attack at the memorial service.
I get out of my Dorky hippie Ford fusion hybrid at the Church and see a smoking
hot chick climbing out of a white 2010 Ford Mustang gt with racing stripes and
walks inside.
Dude,
that sounds like the beginning of a great fucking movie.
You know,
the nerd and his little douchey car.
And then some Hottie,
you know,
was it Christie Brinkley from those fucking a European vacation movies?
Um,
anyways,
it was mysterious and intriguing at the same time.
Exactly.
Uh,
I didn't know too many people at the funeral and uh,
I was the only guy.
Okay.
What?
I didn't know too many people here as I only met the guy through my younger
brother.
It was not super close with him.
Then what the fuck are you doing with the funeral?
At the funeral.
Jesus Christ.
I'm his mother was an artist,
so after,
after the receiving line,
there was a reception with her art displayed around the room and I was sipping
coffee and looking at some of her art.
This is a fucking coolest funeral.
Looking at some of our art on the wall,
I glanced to my right and there she is standing right next to me.
I lean in and I say,
I like your car.
45 minutes later after learning,
she is a nurse at a local hospital and graduated from my,
I learned that she was a nurse from a local hospital and graduated from my high
school.
Okay,
dude,
is this girl like a call girl?
If this sounds like a fucking call girl,
she just shows up in a hot car dressed like a fucking Hati.
Yeah,
and she's a fleshy wearing the nurse's outfit.
Anyways,
he goes on to say,
I knew her family a little bit.
She loves sports.
Oh,
love sports care.
I decided to say goodbye to her and not ask for her number.
I mean,
it's a fucking funeral,
dude.
There's no rules when it comes to getting late.
Okay.
I don't give a shit if you're fucking tread water after a tsunami.
All right?
She didn't have time to put a brown.
She's got a t shirt on.
What you,
you're not going to fucking,
you know,
can't ask for a number at that point or fucking cell phones underwater,
I guess.
You know.
Hey,
you want to uh,
form a two person circle over here.
I heard it keeps the sharks away.
Sorry.
I'm anyways,
Blah Blah Blah.
But thanks to Facebook I get,
I find a route.
I find where the fuck she is her name and she has all these pictures.
Uh,
uh,
but she has all these pictures of her and some Chunky kid worse than the college
version of me.
She also has some status about a great Valentine's Day about,
but nothing about being in a relationship.
I know this sounds like teeny bop ship at this girl was amazing.
We hit it off and I sure don't want to fuck it up with some awkward shit.
We've exchanged a few emails and stuff,
but I don't know how to find out her deal without just asking.
I also don't want to come on too strong and ruined the friendship fetus by
creeping her out.
I want to ask her to her.
I want to ask her to the antisocial network show that you guys are doing with
Jim Norton.
Jim Breuer and David Tell,
uh,
but I have a real fear of ruining the great vibe we have with something she
might not be accepting.
All right.
Do what's you're basically doing by sitting here.
Being timid is you're getting yourself into that Chris rock friend zone.
You have to meet.
You have to make a move right now.
You talked to her at the fucking funeral,
talked to you for 45 minutes of at a funeral.
You didn't ask for the number right there.
You should have lost the game,
but because everybody gets a ribbon with this generation,
this Facebook,
so you get to fucking make it up.
Now she's exchanging emails with you.
How many more fucking clues do you need?
She has a vague sort of relationship status on her Facebook.
Ask her to the fucking shell.
It's perfect.
All right.
You're going to a comedy show will make her laugh.
You sit there laughing it up with our accidentally put her hand on your hand on
a fucking thigh and your red.
I know it's not that easy,
but dude,
you need to ask her out sooner rather than fucking later.
And a have a go to a comedy shelf.
That'd be a great,
I think that'd be a great idea.
And a,
that's it.
All right,
so ask a route.
That's my advice for this fucking week and I apologize for my horrific reading.
Let me give you some youtube videos here.
That'll all be up on theM podcast.com.
The official fan,
a website of the Monday morning podcasts.
We had 7,500 hits last week.
That's the most we've ever gotten.
So I want to thank everybody who has been going there.
Um,
so here we go.
Here's a youtube videos for the weekend.
If you don't want to go up and look at them individually on Youtube,
you can look at them all right.
And our neat little row on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
All right,
for those of you who are into drugs,
man,
um,
we got a great one,
about a 1961.
It's a video on mushrooms and I believe,
I can't really tell what's going on here.
Uh,
I think it's the beginning of ecstasy.
I have no idea what,
but it's just great listening to the weird music that they're playing when they
describe what these mushrooms do to you.
Um,
Elvis is date rape,
blue,
Hawaii Blue Hawaii trailer.
Um,
it's just a bunch of clips of Elvis right before he bangs.
A lot of checks and some of the shit that he gets away with just being mean and
being really misogynistic and not to mention what's fucking hilarious is he
doesn't have a shirt on in most of it cause he's on the beach and you just to
see what being in shape look like.
Back in the day.
He has no abs and he has these little seventh grade arms in a little fucking
chest,
little chicken chess,
but basically in shit,
in shape back in the fifties and sixties just meant you weren't fat.
Uh,
he just suck in your gut a little bit,
but,
uh,
he has the most horrific bathing suit I've ever seen in my life.
And uh,
I dunno,
you could basically do a nine hour seminar at a feminist convention if,
if they just show this entire,
just the movie trailer alone.
Um,
and this is a bizarre video,
is a hidden camera bridge.
Cunt threatens to ruin ex's life.
This guy's marriage is falling apart and he's filming it.
It's just really bizarre.
Uh,
if you like watching something really fucking awkward,
just definitely check it out.
And um,
oh,
here's a new one.
This is what I call a pre nine 11.
These youtube videos.
We just see people doing shit in public that nowadays would end with a felony
and the person on TV scolding them.
Um,
I know I've showed this video before,
but man jumps out of stands and catches football just in case for the new
podcast listeners on one Monday night football game,
uh,
the bears first,
the packers,
somebody kicked a field goal and as it's going through the uprights,
this guy jumps out of the stands and catches it.
I mean,
you'd get tasered and you'd be put in jail immediately.
Now,
and not only does this guy not get tasered,
he goes back to the fucking stance.
He's allowed to continue watching the game.
And Dan Deardorff and Al Al Michaels had just laughing their fucking asses off
thick.
It's the greatest thing ever.
And it just makes me think about,
oh,
it wasn't a great before nine 11,
we didn't get to have a great time and do shit like that.
And it was just considered all innocent fun.
And it didn't have to be treated like it was that it was at a a Sama bin.
Ladin who just jumped out of the fucking stance and a,
all right,
the next youtube video,
this is a,
this is one for John Bonam fans.
This is a very rare video,
or just one I've never seen.
It's a Paul Mccartney video where it's Paul Mccartney and wings and friends at
some horrifically awful,
awful song called the a rock stra theme.
But they,
you know,
one of those things where they put together like an all star cast of people to
raise money.
I'm kind of like a precursor to the,
we are the world thing and they have three drummers to three drummers and one of
them is John Bonam is not only is he not playing Ludwig's,
he's playing this drum kit.
I don't know if it's a north drum kit or there was another drum kit out there
called the sting ray in the late seventies and early eighties.
They had these,
uh,
this radical design on the drums where they sort of had the bottom of the drum.
It looks like it's made,
if you out were on acid and you were looking at a drum kit,
looks like it's melted and it's pointed out at the crowd.
Allegedly it made your Tom sound better,
but it's the only time I've ever seen John Bonham not playing.
Uh,
one of his famous Ludwig kits in any of the drummers out there.
Can you please tell me what the kid is?
Cause I looked it up on the internet.
I tried to find images of sting,
ray drum kits,
and um,
I saw a couple of the modern ones where they had the warp,
uh,
Tom's,
but I couldn't find any of the classic ones.
Uh,
I look through my old modern drummer one magazines and I couldn't find it.
But if anybody knows the name of the drum kit,
I'd love to know.
Uh,
all right.
And that's it.
I think that's it for this,
uh,
for this week.
Um,
yeah,
that's it.
A couple of movies.
Somebody says to move.
We do avoid battle Los Angeles.
Uh,
it is,
it was like Independence Day took a shit all over the expendables.
Just didn't buy into it.
Maybe it's because I've been sober for a while and I saw it with a few potheads
who loved it to death.
Wouldn't shut the fuck up during the movie and kept making stupid comments like,
dude,
we're fucked.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
come on.
Who goes to Bat Los Angeles and actually thinks it's going to be cherry.
It's a fire.
Which I actually thought that movie sucked.
Uh,
yeah,
I think you need to smoke the meat.
That's the movie that that movie is for.
Potheads that's one.
You know,
you don't eat a fucking,
you know,
a little weed cookie and go see and have a good time.
Um,
seat.
That's right there.
There you go.
There's something positive about weed.
It makes mu awful movies like battle Los Angeles enjoyable and like relevant.
And somebody said Lincoln Lincoln lawyer was awesome.
All right,
that's it.
That is the podcast for this week.
You guys all have a great week.
Thanks for everybody who,
uh,
listens to the Monday morning podcast.
If you want to hear that epic argument,
uh,
that I had with a red band,
you know,
and yes,
we are friends.
We got along great.
Actually did a set itselves comedy whole,
we laughed about the arguments.
So you know,
there's no reason to gossip anything beyond if you just really want to listen to
a great argument of two people who just don't know how to say,
agree to disagree,
uh,
I definitely suggest to listen to.
I also definitely recommend subscribing to Joe Rogan's podcast.
It's fucking awesome.
I had a great time on it and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I will see some of you at the Gibson MP theater on April 2nd for the,
uh,
Kevin and been comedy show that raises money for,
I forget what cause I know it's a great cause because no one ever raises money
for terrorists.
Right?
I guess unless you do a comedy show and like Saudi Arabia,
isn't that what they do?
You know,
that's how they raised money with their filthy fucking oil money.
Then they funnel it through the mosque is not how it goes down cause that other
paper trail goes down.
Do you guys leave?
Read Rolling Stone magazine?
You've got to check it out on these two pot heads who became international arms
dealers.
It's really interesting to watch too.
Kids get involved in that type of shit.
And also to see how that game is run and also kind of makes you understand
whilst why certain countries really do not like other countries and kind of
what's going on,
it's just completely fucked.
Um,
so I definitely rank,
recommend checking that out,
man.
I,
that's it.
All right.
Can I just shut the fuck up now?
I'm going to shut the fuck up now.
All right.
You guys have a great week.
Go Fuck yourself and I'll talk to you later.
[inaudible].